the rams offense uh they didn't choke
last night they won the game we touched
on this earlier when we were trying to
make sense of the mitchell trubisky
benching unless it wasn't a benching
unless it was a benching but maybe jared
goff should be benched for blake bortles
well i don't know if i'd go that far but
yeah
yeah i mean
two of your favorite quarterbacks are on
the bottom
yeah and um hey i think i've tried to be
fair to jared goff like we're in games
where they lost the bucks and lost to
the seahawks i think you can remember i
actually came back and defended him
those days and said he made a lot of
great throws and great plays
but
fortunately or unfortunately for him you
know and a lot of the wins he's played
below average football that that's the
biggest problem they are a defensive
football team at this point and i
understand that you know he's missing a
few weapons and their own lines not as
dominant but again when you're being
paid like what does he mike one of the
five highest points thirty three and a
half in a year right he's gotta be top
five right in the league somewhere in
that range um
you know
last night's game when you watch it go
back and watch i mean they're managing
the number one pick in the draft in year
four or is it year five year five
going in after a year he went to the
super bowl where they don't even trust
him to throw the ball on third and three
or third and four or third and five they
don't even want to mess with it because
they're just like oh gosh well we don't
know what he'll do and we're playing the
bear so we'll let our defense just stop
them but yeah i think it's just
concerning from that aspect you know the
interception he threw certainly didn't
give sean mcveigh the confidence uh
there either and shawn mcveigh was going
to just run the ball and play defense
and see if he could win the game that
way and not let jared goff screw it up
and that's what that game said to me
last night how is this sustainable
though if the offense is built to have
your franchise quarterback not screw
things up yeah no it's not sustainable
there's no way they'll be able to beat
the elite teams in football that way
they're going to get away with teams
where
yeah you know like we saw with
pittsburgh you know they can hang in
there because pittsburgh's offense
thinks too so they depended on their
defense and if jared goff doesn't have a
fumble that's picked up for a touchdown
they win the game 12 to 10 right i mean
that's that's that's really where it's
gotten to and um yeah it's concerning to
me and again i just go back to the point
and it's just funny that blake bortles
is on the roster with him where the rams
negotiated against themselves you said
it they backed themselves into this
corner and then it builds up the public
perception that jared goff is really
really special and of course he's from
california and there's that aspect of it
too and a lot of the fans just see oh
the team got better and jared goff was
the starting quarterback that must be
the reason no it's not the reason it's
not and um i would be concerned if i'm
in the rams organization i've had people
ask me surely the
comments made publicly by sean mcvay
praising jared goff excessively and
repeatedly surely those don't become
fodder for an agent to
make the case for the guy to get a
contract and for the guy to get a market
value contract and the answer is yes
they do that's what agents do
i had someone who i respect who
understands how this business works a
long time ago say
the biggest problem a team can create
for itself when things are going well is
to praise gratuitously and excessively
its own players because the agents will
use that when it's time to negotiate and
it's going to cost you more money you're
trying to hold your team together you're
trying to make it all fit and you can't
afford to have these gratuitous
statements you think bill belichick ever
says anything good about anybody yeah
and that's one of the reasons why he
doesn't he doesn't want to cost himself
more money and so with sean mcvay
pushing back against guys like you and
me yeah who were criticizing god for his
performance in the super bowl and also
pointing out maybe goff is the
quarterback that
hears for the first time among these
high level guys sorry we're not
interested in a second contract right
and it was a big to-do back in june when
i went on dan patrick's show and said
that hey maybe goff doesn't get a second
contract maybe dak prescott does and
jared goff doesn't but people in league
circles didn't think you were crazy for
that god either but that's what people
sean mcveigh decided to push back and
push back and push back and it set the
stage for ryan toner to go to the rams
and say time to pay up yeah sure well
it's a dicey conversation it's a dicey
spot for sean mcvay to be in because
also because hey as we know there's not
always better out there right so you got
to be careful about oh maybe you know
the grass isn't always greener on the
other side and they have won games and
he's trying to he knows he had him this
year so he's trying to instill
confidence in him going into the 2019
season to you know build them up and
make them feel good and the offense and
team feel good about the leadership at
the quarterback position after a
piss-poor super bowl performance like
you mentioned so yeah that's you know i
think coupled with you know him and the
fact that todd gurley is the second
highest paid running back in football
and is clearly not the same you know
again i'll just say there there was runs
last night and the screenplays were yeah
he got some yards but i sat there and
went
old todd gurley's head would have hit
the goal post and we would have struck
up the band and had been touched down
instead it's a 10-yard gain or a 15-yard
gain so there you have your two
highest-paid offensive players who are
not performing at a level to where
they're being paid and that's what i
always say right i mean follow the money
the money on your team if it's not
performing usually your team's not
performing either and they have a lot of
their salary cap invested in those two
guys and they signed todd gurley a year
before they should have and they regret
it now they would probably admit that
although you may have to give them
sodium pentothal and or a couple of
shots of tequila and they're going to
regret signing jared goff early and
look
i like sean mcvay me too that's what
makes this difficult but you know what
that's part of his strategy i think and
he's got that la media wrapped around
his finger where they want to ask him
tough questions at press conferences
because he uses their name he's
incredibly charismatic
well that's a good question chris and
look i'm not hey that it may be genuine
i'm not saying it's funny it is genuine
i've never seen them not like that but
the point is the point is right
it makes it harder
for the people in the media as a
practical matter to get on and they like
him they don't want to push him and they
tiptoe around todd gurley's knee all the
time they tiptoe around jared goff's
performance all the time and it's it's
kind of interesting to watch it unfold
because not every coach gets the benefit
of that kind of of of courtesy from the
media that covers his team yeah no
you're right yeah well it seems like the
rams have la on lockdown i mean it does
dude you know yeah because you got
people in the rams organization who i
believe are are doing everything they
can to create the sense that the
chargers aren't going to be there for
very long so it's a great way to keep
the chargers down while they are done
well that that certainly seems like a
fair point to make too i mean i
certainly thought that as well and you
know i think when it goes back and what
you're saying about sean mcvay it's very
real but i've known sean since he was
you know a low-level assistant with the
tampa bay buccaneers he's always been
that way highly respectful looks you in
the eye yes sir no sir hey mentioned you
by the name so it is him it's not like
an act or anything like that but it
works well when you're in a situation
where people may be asking you tough
questions it definitely does it plays to
his favor and there's no doubt and i'm
sure he realizes that too he is as smart
as they come and really what i go back
to here is
this is on sean mcvay and sean mcgee is
going to figure it out he's just too
intelligent of a guy to where you know
even last night we saw changes in their
offense already where i went oh
different formations i haven't seen them
do that this year different personnel
sets screen passes became part of the
play all together i think he realized
hey i can't trust my offense so i'm
gonna go you know to the dark side and
play defensive football punt it out do
things like that i mean that's that's
the way he played it and i think he'll
reevaluate and figure out a new formula
it's better than pulling jared goff off
the field and putting blake bortles in
to run a read option on third and short
well yeah that was a definitely a
skeptical moment last week in that
pittsburgh steelers game but uh i think
the game we saw last night is what we're
going to see a lot from the rams down
the stretch jaylen ramsey aaron donald
littleton in the middle
you know dante fowler they got some
dudes on that defense wade phillips is a
hell of a coach and they're gonna ask
their defense to be the
the you know the strength of that
football team and they're going to play
through that and they're only going to
push the envelope on offense when they
deem like okay we have to we're down in
this moment and now we need jared goff
to make some throws and you know hey he
made a big throw last night you know for
that one post touchdown and everything
like that but you know again for what
he's being paid and what we're expecting
out of him it has to be more than just a
one play a game or this or that it's
just not enough and i think we would all
agree with that anybody watching
football i think would agree with that
right now
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports